hello good human Oh welcome to another
episode of hot man now what are we
wearing we're wearing the good few
minutes sweater you guys asked for we
got like so many DMS from people asking
for the sweater so we are dropping
another limited badge available on good
human la comm that's right yeah we love
it we hope you love it it allows us to
make more videos as well so thank you
for that and for now enjoy this episode
alright what's your favorite candy most
candies without gelatin in it name wine
or wine foods
okay those aren't vegan we brought
together seven vegans I'm I'm a vegan I
am vegan vegan one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives he or she wins the entire prize
okay Brandon what do you eat for
breakfast this morning I had buckwheat
buckwheat hot cereal add almond milk and
some water okay who eats buckwheat in
the morning like I know people do but
I'm looking at him and his body language
and how he's telling me and I'm going
you just had buckwheat
ie buckwheat every single day for
breakfast and I feel like that's a
normal thing but everyone acted like it
was a real thing I'll be honest I
everything on bread I have to do because
like I just I'm a recent vegan I've been
vegan for like five months it's a
challenge I did for myself I have a
question what are y'all favorite
restaurants you guys check out in North
Hollywood is this like awesome it's
really it's Cajun vegan yes yeah you
know you I really been taking I talked I
took my friend Hannah she's actually a
big youtuber as well everything that
came out of his mouth was super random
Brandon what's your favorite restaurant
I gonna talk about all the time what do
you get at Taco Bell I get a contract
but swap out the beef and get some beans
in there also swap out the sour cream
and the cheese yeah
something use eggs in there like in
their raps I hope they don't yeah I hope
they don't either because then that
wouldn't be vegan I don't know why she
was coming at me I don't know if it's
like the way I look I don't look like a
vegan why is everyone here at vegan I'm
vegan because I actually moved out here
I felt like I was like all right if I
mess up I can keep on doing it so I
challenged myself on five months in and
I was like alright I'm gonna continue
doing it because I can you the salmon
was just taking up all the time so that
I couldn't find any information about
anybody I'm vegan because of the
environment I think the meat and dairy
industry just contributes way too much
to our environmental issues and so
that's why I decided to go vegan I've
been vegan for almost three years I kind
of just fold like blogs and stuff and
then I found out I had like high
cholesterol I like cold turkey just like
put it the more I learned about it and
educated myself the more I wanted to
keep going I initially went vegan for my
health for my skin it's kind of helped
it hasn't helped that much but I think
just when I was doing it I was like why
go back kind of like you like I could do
it and I don't think there was a huge
like pressing environmental factor just
like I can do it right now so why
exactly go back and it's like being good
so it's almost been like a year so
Kirsten where do you I became vegan for
animal cruelty reasons it's a whole
bunch of stuff you know you can go into
but yeah for animal reasons and
environmental reasons and health reasons
so I've been vegan for almost 10 years
combined started off when I was 21 years
old I was drinking heavily and I just
wanted to be feeling like better in my
body so I took a yoga class when if he
can / and I went raw vegan for two years
I became a raw food chef I'm a yoga
teacher now yeah I went vegan Khanna has
like a transition I was pescetarian for
10 years what is your favorite
documentary that helped you go with that
Oh helped me go vegan I kind of watch
like those YouTube lon which ones like
what what name one I don't remember the
names I like saw them in the blogs that
I was talking about and like which blog
um it was called
it was like this girl her name is Emma I
gave her the sign I like mm-hmm you
don't know what blog you don't know what
post you don't know this you don't know
you don't know anything
I watched the VR this actually helped
encourage me and I watched um from a
first-person perspective yeah cows
getting butchered from you can see them
getting cut up
she had a little more makeup on and she
had nail polish on and so I guess in my
head I think vegans just go further more
natural it's sort of look I was like
looking for some cues and like what
people were wearing and he was wearing
like suede shoes most like vegans don't
really wear leather okay I was really
shocked I think it was a little bit shy
in the beginning when Aaron was grilling
me I just got really nervous and like I
forgot the names of everything and I was
like there's cameras here and like
everyone's watching me like the time is
ticking and what is your favorite soap
that you use oh my gosh I'm more vegan
for like food-related reasons right but
typically like if you're vegan do you
use all your partner's I identify as a
vegan but I do it more so for
food-related reason it's not exactly
because I'd like did it for my health
yeah do you wear a leather I don't own
leather it's interesting I own leather
but I don't buy leather is leather that
has been bought years ago that I still
have that I feel this kind of like
wasteful I like throw away important
things you don't buy yeah because we
vote with our dollars exactly I think
like in this circle like there would
still be people who like identify
themselves as vegan even if it's like
food-related or like something
outrageous but yeah I think like the odd
man how would it be someone who like
yeah is like me like just doing it for
free yes yeah ask me questions too I
like questions actually don't you think
I don't honey sure yes I I don't I just
don't at all
I honey honey is it vegan I think they
made me feel like my reason for being a
vegan wasn't good enough because it
wasn't coming from the same place that
they were I have a question yeah so okay
everyone think about the immediate
circle how many folks in your circle are
vegan I'm supported by my circle yeah
like they thought I was unhealthy at
first because I wasn't gay
to eat mm-hmm and I don't hold what
guess issues um that was so far you've
said that you don't really consider
yourself vegan because the products you
use I would like go like the extra mile
and like lie and like say like I try my
best
oh no it's been like less than a year
like eight months actually there the
fresco style at Taco Bell is supposed to
be vegan Ida he didn't mention that he
said that he got the taco and then he
removed everything and then he mentioned
that later on I have seen vegan
youtubers who like go to talkin like you
can make it vegan just to show people
that like it can be like convenience I
don't know why you guys why don't you go
there if you're vegan
I thought Aaron was pretty aggressive
but in all the best ways for a game like
this like she asked all they're like
heavy hitting questions which is exactly
how it should have been what's your
favorite candy favorite candy most
candies without gelatin in it nerdy one
name one nerd sorry that's our best kids
okay those aren't vegan I thought they
were but okay maybe I'm not a vegan I uh
like I don't I don't I thought they were
what I mean you know what's your
favorite candy
I don't eat candy really yeah I don't it
didn't seem that his ethics and his
values were in alignment with the diet
because typically when you are vegan
everything surrounding you matches that
I'm not like really a part of the vegan
community I feel like I have one vegan
friend I could have had five vegan
friends but they voted me out so so we
raise our hand if we think he's still in
here I think they might but no I think
raise your hand if you think the mole is
still in the square
if the lights turned green you voted the
liar out if the lights turn red the
liars fill in the boss and you lose okay
everyone let's never so I feel a little
bit more secure in this
literally whispered to Aaron I think is
jaylen I think it's June so I'm a little
mad little Sawa a little broke
I have watched too much survivor been
like first round
get me thrown in I was tested to see if
I was gonna trip up in my words how much
knowledge I actually had I'm like if I
go first I can speak the most and make
it seem like an accident
so I just want time to run out so I felt
good because people got annoyed and they
didn't want to hear from me so they
pushed me aside started talking
everybody else I got one from my fam I
got one from my fam I got one for me one
for my new Xbox all right I'm pretty
frustrated because I think I could have
won if I hadn't just been affected by
everybody else's doubtfulness I was
reminded of the different perspectives
of veganism I don't think you can really
like see a vegan it's more like their
thoughts like their ideology and how
they think about the worlds thanks for
watching guys we really appreciate it
and we love making this stuff for you
absolutely
tell us what you thought in the comments
below and also tell us your episode
ideas we do read all the comments people
think we're some kind of giant
corporation but we do read the Romans
we're not robots anyways we'll see you
guys around and peace out alright guys